now's the turn of the leader of the
Liberal Democrats the Deputy Prime
Minister Nick Clegg Thank You mr. clay
yes please take take the hot seat okay
first question new doctors working in a
major hospital I think the biggest thing
we can do which we're not going to do
overnight
is work out how we can keep people
healthier in their own homes and their
own communities so that we don't have an
increasing number of people going to A&E
for problems that could have been
anticipated earlier it sounds like very
simple but it's actually very complex
it's complex because well a bunch of
reasons one of them as your parents did
you say both of them working oh yeah do
they work on the same A&E and they've
seen a massive increase in yeah well
they would probably tell you it would be
my guess but but correct me if I'm wrong
that one of the things that's happened
in A&E is that we have an increasingly
large number of elderly people with with
with conditions which they might fall a
home they might have a long term
condition which means they're in and out
of hospital they then go into hospital
by A&E they then go into hospital bed
and then it's very difficult sometimes
even though maybe your mum and dad of
the clinicians of judge that they're
ready to leave hospital to find a place
to look after them in the community and
that's the social care system so in the
jargon what everyone's been talking
about for ages but which we now need to
get up and get on and do is integrate
social care and healthcare that's the I
think that's one of the probably the
biggest changes we can that we can make
I think there's some other things we can
do my personal point of view personal
view is that if we can put the treatment
of mental health conditions on the same
footing as long being provided to
physical health problems I think that
would have a transformative effect on
the NHS because a lot of people again
your mum and dad might might confirm
this will go to a doctor or even go to
A&E with physical problems which quite
often have mental health origins but
because mental health has been
underfunded under underappreciated acts
slightly brushed under the carpet for a
long period of time it's been a an issue
around which there's been far too much
of a sort of embarrassment to sort of
push foot shuffling taboo I think we can
put mental health and physical health on
the same footing and that would make a
huge huge difference as well so look I
put probably at the top of my list would
be making sure that social care and
health care work together better so that
people don't end up staying in hospital
beds for longer than is necessary and
making sure that mental health is given
exactly the same you know for instance
waiting time standards and access
standards which we've long had for
physical health issues are only now
gonna start coming in over the next year
or two for mental health problems I
think those two things would make the
biggest difference in my view yeah
anything else on the NHS who wants to
come in with lots of questions on the
NHS let's say go hear the battle I just
wanted to know don't you think one of
the biggest reasons for the increase in
waiting times is the 2012 health and
care social act which your government
passed in 2012 which is privatized most
some of our NHS what would you comment
on that I don't agree with that at all
if you actually look at the facts rather
than some of the myths allegations
around what's happening for instance
with the private sector the independent
sector when this coalition government
came into power in May 2010 the previous
government had increased the amount of
all of the NHS money your money that's
used in the independent of private
sector to I think was around four
percent of the total it's now six
percent so the idea that you know a two
percent addition to something which was
really much larger inherited from labour
is some great mass privatization
complete utter nonsense there's no
evidence to suggest that is the case at
all actually
what lay behind what was at the heart of
that much maligned and much commented on
piece of legislation actually goes back
so what's your name and it says a
question which is how do we how do we
take an NHS which was designed basically
for a different country a different time
when when it was all about hospitals
when it wasn't about mental health was
about keeping people healthier in the
community to a to a kind of 21st century
Britain where people are living much
more
much longer and the the whole point of
that bill there's nothing to do with
privatization it was all to do about
trying to put the authority about
decisions about where money goes to in
the NHS in the hands of people who know
best namely clinicians why because it
was our view and it remains my view that
if you want to make sure that we keep
people as healthy as possible without
them having to resort to going to AMA
and without the languishing in hospital
beds the most important thing to do is
to empower GPS empower clinicians to put
money where it can help people keep them
healthy we don't we we can't have an NHS
which is purely designed on dealing with
dealing with people's health when it's
already gone wrong shortly we want a
health system which keeps people healthy
doesn't just provide the emergency
remedies when things go wrong and that
in a nutshell is what that that
legislation was trying difficult though
it is trying to deliver Thank You Joseph
onus we've got a slightly related
question from Facebook which is going to
come up there why why do important
life-saving services always suffer but
there's money for Trident so I kind of
tried in a minute and because I
personally think the like flight
replacement for Trident advocated by
Labour and conservatives is a nonsense
cause it is it's just it's just obvious
this was a nuclear weapon system that
was designed to flatten Moscow the touch
of a button in the Cold War well we
clearly don't we clearly don't live in
that same world and of course we should
be coming down the nuclear ladder as it
happens I wish there was a great pot of
gold in doing that I've been told by the
experts that decommissioning a nuclear
weapon system costs a huge amount of
money anyway so I don't think it says
what in it look in other words whilst I
might agree with I think what is lies
behind the question that we shouldn't
just stick with Trident as it is I'm
afraid changing tack on Trident doesn't
necessarily suddenly produce
miraculously a whole bunch of money for
the NHS look only money point on the NHS
and it comes later to your two questions
and of course we need to safeguard the
budget of the NHS we've actually done
that in this coalition government unlike
many other public services they're the
police about to make twenty percent
savings we've actually increased by over
12 billion pounds the amount of money
going to the NHS the new independent
head so
you know breathe easily not a politician
you can believe what he says
a guy called Simon Stephens has
calculated that by the end of the next
Parliament the funding gap in the NHS
will be 8 billion pounds my party we've
we've we've explained how you find that
money by tightening up some of the tax
exemptions which are provided only to
the very wealthy and also re-linking the
amount of money going into the NHS with
the growth of the economy once the death
the deficit is dealt with so you do need
to protect the budget for the NHS you
need to secure the money that's been
identified by Simon Stephens my point
however would be to the Facebook
questionnaire is that in and of itself
is not enough you need to do the reforms
for an elder in an aging population you
need to do the reforms on on mental
health and those reforms as well because
if you don't do that you're just going
to put money into a system that isn't
yet properly you know working for all of
us hi I'm at school currently in sick
form and almost everybody that I know
agrees that we don't have enough
teaching on life skills such as drug
education sex education even politics
and there's such pressure on teachers in
schools to deliver exam syllabus is that
they've just not got time how would you
tackle that if you came to power well
I'll tell you one thing where I'd start
where bluntly I just haven't been able
to make progress with them the
Conservative Party and coalition is if
you take citizenship classes right any
of you hands on those you thought you're
citizen classes when you're at school
art school were any good those are the
classes weren't any good mmm and those
of you who just didn't have it at all
yeah well that shows the mixed bag that
I think said good citizenship classes
are as those who put their hands up who
said you did have good classes are a
really good thing they empower people
they teach you know youngsters about the
world they live and they teach about
politics democracy and so on the
requirement at the moment to teach some
kind of citizenship cook class is there
for norm is like normal maintain schools
but not for academies and free schools
so why is that
Why should there be a requirement
requirement for it to be taught to
thousands and thousands of schools
across the country but not to certain
other schools which just so happen to
have a different name plate at the
school gates
same with them personal sex relationship
education incredibly important
incredibly important to empower
youngsters to feel that their you know
that they kind of can take responsible
decisions would you enforce at that yes
I would I would so one of the exactly as
I was alluding to I have long thought I
mean you know something you bite might
be not familiar with but you might you
know you might have come across the
whole phenomenon of online bullying and
and kind of sort of sometimes sort of
sexual intimidation you can see online
that's a new threat for a lot of young
people that didn't exist not when I grew
up it's quite recent that's the kind of
thing actually we're having universal
courses on sex health education
relationship education schools I think
could really help a lot of vulnerable
youngsters for some reason that asked
David Cameron when he comes here the
conservative just got some ideological
view that that shouldn't be taught or
you shouldn't insist that it should be
taught in free schools and academies
it's a nonsense if it's taught in one
school surely it should be taught in all
schools and that's what I think should
happen because I think it helps
youngsters prepare for a lot of the
perils and pitfalls that now exist
thanks that Sam we're gonna move on in
just let Luke come back on that point
yeah so you were saying about life
skills and being taught within schools
what about services outside of schools
like NCS their National Citizen Service
where they build on life skills and give
young people kind of a feeling of
purpose independence you think that's a
priority I think they're great and and
not only those projects there are
thousands upon thousands of outstanding
community projects that take youngsters
who from the most I know the toughest
backgrounds all have kind of fallen foul
of their teachers or you know kind of
being disruptive or whatever I mean this
morning actually in South West London I
visited a rugby sports scheme that
caters for kids from you know who
basically had some real problems at
school and it's wonderful to see because
basically through sports they're giving
those youngsters who otherwise might
fall by the wayside a real sense of
comfort
I visited a number of boxing clubs but
get some of the most you know some of
the most kind of disruptive kids and
turn them into quite self disciplined
youngsters so I don't you should be
prescriptive about it I think the worse
thing to do is to have politicians or
central government sort of say this is
you know thou shalt do this or that
project but we do need to give support
to all of those community projects that
help making sure make sure that
youngsters who otherwise might fall by
the wayside in stay instead stay at
school do well and have a better future
thank you Joe a minister Luke Joe your
subjects yeah completely hi my name is
Luke and I was actually night eighteen
nineteen when the last election was
around and you were the first people I
voted for the big issue I have is is
that I now feel responsible for my
sister NAFTA pay three times the amount
of tuition fees first question really
boils down to why should we feel like we
can trust you obviously we understand it
was part of a coalition and that
combinations have to be made but we've
seen now that actually as we all knew
originally it's not going to work out
the high and tuition fees it's not going
to get repaid what's your stance are you
are you sorry for the fact that you
weren't able to reduce it to is it
reduced to zero their tuition fees so
I've apologized musically no less no
kindest best actually the very important
points your sister yeah so your sisters
it's really important just forget you
know politics and and you know and I'll
come to that in a minute of course so
god I've always taken this on the chin
I'll do it again I just for your sister
and for people wanting to go to
university
please don't what you said somehow
suggests that she is paying three times
she's not which is the reason of course
why despite all the predictions at the
time more youngsters are now going to
university never before more youngsters
from disadvantaged backgrounds are going
to university than ever before more
youngsters from black minority ethnic
backgrounds are going to university than
ever before why because unlike the fee
system that you had under the previous
Labor government your sister doesn't
have to pay anything upfront and she
doesn't have to pay anything back only
until she can afford to do so why I say
that's so important is if she can't pay
it off she doesn't have
if she's on lo pages of to pay a penny
if she's not working she doesn't have to
pay a penny and the reason I say that is
because I don't I don't want to shirk
the political controversy I'll come back
to that but for your sister and for the
thousands of youngsters are going to
university it's really important that
she knows and they know that there is
absolutely no impediment going to
university whatsoever and in many
respects let me give you an example if
your sister what course is she doing in
university she's currently doing
childhood studies she's doing childhood
sorry let's say she goes to what to do
early years work and yes yeah let's say
she goes into early years work and she
ends up getting paid I don't know
roughly this average income these days
or twenty-four twenty-five thousand
pounds in this country under the old fee
system she would have had to pay sixty
seven quid a month right under the labor
fee system for that she will now have to
pay a third of that twenty two pounds a
month she might have to pay longer but
she will have to pay much less every
week and every month I only give you
those facts because because of the fury
and the anger and so on sometimes I
think the facts have been a little bit
lost now on to your question what I've
course hope politically I don't I don't
I don't I've never sure at the fact that
I'm not Prime Minister we have 9% of MPs
Liberal Democrat MPs in government in
Parliament I didn't win the election
therefore of course we can't implement
alas the full liberal the manifesto in
full I will of course be saying to you
and to everybody else I hope that as as
well as judging me and my party on the
one thing we haven't been able to do you
also give us credit for the hundreds of
things that we have done lower taxes
more apprenticeships fairer pensions
better better education for youngsters
by giving them free healthy meals at
lunchtime the pupil premium
transformative experience in schools for
kids for the most disadvantaged
backgrounds but of course I'm not going
to shirk the fact I've never hidden from
the fact that if you are a party in a in
a coalition the government coalition
means you can't get your way on
everything and we clearly give them that
both labour and the Conservatives wanted
to see fees go up there was no way that
we could implement our own policy one
sentence what's your response to that
yeah I just wanted to say actually that
even though you said that was she's
going to be paying less she is still
paying three times the amount she still
has three times the amount of debt and
that will still be looming over her
you're encouraging with this up with
this mindset the
that is actually okay to work for less
and Belova targets in order to actually
like not have to pay it you know now
these people now lots of us here are
gonna feel like why should we earn over
20 grand we're gonna have to pay more
debt we're gonna have to pay more stuff
completely open of course so why is it
okay that I should have to feel like I
it's better for me financially not to
earn more it's better for me financially
to take a lower paying job do less hours
focus more on myself than to actually go
and be a contributing member so I'm a
computer science graduate yeah I could
go and do that as a degree option but
you know what I'm gonna have to pay more
money doing that why shouldn't I just go
round take a simple reason which is the
reason of course why fees were
introduced in 2003 was that the evidence
is overwhelming it still remains the
fact that if you have a university
degree your earning power what you can
earn during your working life it's
considerably considerably higher so in
effect the decision that was taken well
before my party came into government by
the previous Labour administration was
that the costs of a higher education are
shared by the taxpayers generally many
of whom of course have never been lucky
enough to go to university but partly by
the increased earnings that graduates
earn because they've been to university
so that's the system we inherited of
course as you know my party couldn't
implement and by the way look I you
quite rightly alluded to of course I've
apologized for the fact that that
particular policy of my parties we
couldn't implement I sometimes wish I
only point this out I sometimes wish I
could hear an apology from David Cameron
for not implementing his policy that he
promised he would on immigration or Ed
Miliband for crashing the economy in the
first place but there you go that's the
way these things are what I do think I
could I'm entitled to say is if you look
at the details of the system we've put
in place it was the next best thing it
is in effect like it is in effect like a
graduate acts you only pay when you can
and uni pay what you can afford - I'll
finish off by saying thank you we have
to move on just looking quick responses
to that issue obviously issue Carissa
just gives a couple sentences I mean
that being said as you said that over
the three years were basically paying we
basically have to pay for
times more than we will burn your
universe no but the thing is if why
should I be paying that much amount for
money when I may even secure the
graduate job after that's okay we'll
just take a couple more you don't get in
other ways if you don't get a job which
which pays well then you don't pay
anything at all yeah but for here's that
here's here's the thing okay forget the
politics of coalition's forget me to get
the Liberal Democrats if you had carried
on with the system before right the fee
system which was introduced by labor in
2003 it's really important you
understand this when you left university
you would have to start paying back the
moment you started earning fifteen
thousand pounds which is not a very high
income right under the new system you
don't have to pay when you when you're
only 15 or 16 or 17 or 18 or 19 or 20 or
Twitter you only start paying when you
start paying back when you start earning
21,000 pounds or more so I have to I you
know in the same way that you of course
should be blunt with me I have to be
blunt with you that you've got to
compare this system with a system that
came before it actually and that I think
is one of the reasons why so many more
youngsters are despite all the Ferrari
going to university the new system makes
it more not less affordable of course it
might cause me political embarrassment I
can't do my party's policy all I'm
trying to say to you about and I'm
assuming so I'm making assumptions about
how old you are that you're hoping to go
to university I really really want you
to know that you've paid nothing up
front and you don't pay back nearly as
as punitive Lee as you did under the
system we inherited there's got some
other topics and we'll come back and
we'll try and come back to this Charlene
Charlene and now that's just a great
example of how you went into politics or
you went into that promise and with
great intentions but obviously party
lines party politics stopped you from
doing so now do you ever feel the
overwhelming pressure because of party
politics and and try and see you know to
stay with what your party wants to be
quite your coalition as well do you feel
like you're compromising yourself though
so sure I can I just kind of it's a
really important point this I would love
to be Prime Minister of course I would
I'd love to implement
of course I would it wouldn't human
being of course I'd like there yeah I
can do exactly what I want to do my
whole manifesto in full it's a democracy
I didn't win the election there are nine
of all the MPs in the House of Commons
and nine percent of the Liberal
Democrats I've never hidden from anybody
that if you have a government composed
of different parties by definition
neither party can do everything at once
now some people might like that I've had
a lot of people shouting at me for five
years saying oh I know you do exactly
what you want because I don't have the
mandate to do it I don't have the right
I do not have the democratic right to do
exactly what I want because I didn't win
the election and at the end of the day
it's not whether I'm a liberal democrat
or a label at or whatever you have to be
a Democrat and in a party way you not me
you the people decide that no single
party had the right to run the
government on their own compromise
follows like night follows day what you
then need to do and this is I think is
an important point is be open with
people if you're gonna have to
compromise about what your priorities
are so for instance what you'll hear
from me in the coming weeks is what are
the kind of priorities for the Liberal
Democrats in the run-up to the next
general election so that you Charlene
know that if the Liberal Democrats are
going to be in government again what are
the things that are really gonna fight
for and not necessarily you know ever
compromise on as it happens if you take
out the 2010 Liberal Democrat manifesto
I'm not sure if you have an Edition in
your library but I will yeah I'm sure a
well that will copy if you did you would
see that the four things we put on the
front page of our manifesto we have
delivered you don't pay any tax on the
first 10,000 pounds you earn
we're over delivering on that the two
and a half billion pounds pupil premium
that I referred to earlier we're
delivering that sorting out the economy
we're delivering that pushing for
political reform those are the four
things which we've actually stuck to
religiously now I understand of course
because of a policy that wasn't on our
front page but nonetheless we couldn't
deliver and all the noted variety around
it the allegation is all you have failed
to deliver anything you've promised
that's simply not true
look at the front page of my manifesto
look at what we've done in government
and I'm actually really proud of what
we've delivered just a quick response to
this from Tom over here
two very quick question one question
very good question if it came to it in
2015 would you join David Cameron a
coalition again it's still exactly like
last time it's not my choice or his
choice or Ed Miliband's choice it really
is your choice so last time it was
obvious that even though no one no party
had won the election had got a sore
slam-dunk majority the Conservatives got
the most votes in those seats
so I said according to the democratic
principles I was just talking to
Charlene about that in a democracy the
party and it's frankly it's regardless
whether you like them or loathe them if
that party's got more votes and more
seats it has the Democratic right after
an election to seek to form a government
if it wants to which is what the
Conservatives did they then we had
negotiations with them as it happened
there was no other combination it was
possible I spoke to Gordon Brown a
couple of occasions because he wanted to
see whether a Lib Dem labor coalition
could be formed
it was numerically impossible because
labour and Lib Dem MPs don't make up a
majority in the current Parliament so
you know look I'm like anyone in
politics I've got my dreams and my
ideals I'm also a pragmatic person I
have to respond to the instructions
given by the British people and the
instructions last time were that the
only way that we could have a stable
government in this country at a time
when we are crying out for stable
government because the country was
teetering on the edge of an economic
precipice was that particular
combination of conservative Liberal
Democrats but if you guys give us
different instructions next time I will
try and do my Democratic duty to follow
your instructions okay quasi quasi I am
somebody who lives in the padule-- and
says soon to be somebody who lives
independently and says soon to be better
what guarantees do you have to ensure
rent it's affordable for those on low or
moderate incomes sure in is affordable
for those on low or moderate incomes
well or rent I mean I think that there
are there are a number of things need to
do first we need to make sure that
longer longer rent contracts and
agreements are much much more widely
used I think this these short-term
rental arrangement switch really really
can lead think
the lurch are very very unfair indeed
and I mean if you want I can take a
detail separately and give you a give
you some more information about the work
we're doing to make sure that longer
term rentals become the norm rather than
the exception here in London as in large
parts of the country do you know what
I've read endless endless policy
documents at the end of the day our
biggest problem see we just don't build
enough homes we just don't build enough
new properties particularly affordable
properties and we in my judgment need to
build as a country maybe what two
hundred fifty three hundred thousand new
properties every year to simply start
matching the damat of the demand for
people looking for properties not least
not least to rent there's a whole
different ways you can do that I
personally think we can do more to give
local authorities of free a hand to
build to build stuff I think we can use
the muscle of the state of central
government to put finance into housing
more significantly as well but I I would
single out for you making sure that the
rental terms are fairer for people who
are in rented accommodation a and B that
we build more homes on a much larger
scale over a sustained period of time
yes also they are neighbor and then
people hit me and said that she fools
rent controls don't have in New York
will be very seductive idea rental
controls aren't they it's just a
pragmatic question of do they really
work do they really lead to - to the
spread of affordable rent and there I
think to be honest the debate is much
much more mixed they can actually quite
a knock-on effect on squeezing a lot of
people out of rented accommodation
altogether because they make it less
attractive for landlords to come in and
and you know rent out and so that's the
you know unless you think you can sort
of you know do the whole rental thing
without having land rules actually by
house and throwing houses and make them
available for rent unless you think that
I think you've got to be a little bit
careful about the knock-on effects of
rent controls on having more people
invest money in the properties in the
first place which is what you need to
make sure that you've got a roof over
your head
let's get another subject in morado an
apprentice
September was lucky enough to defer
University place to take up a job
however many of my friends have went
apprenticeships that pay as little as
two pounds 73 an hour less than the bus
fare to and from work with no guarantee
of a job at the end what would you do to
change the situation and improve
apprenticeships so the the minimum wage
for Prentice ships your right is set
differently as you quite rightly alluded
to to the 650 minimum wage for a reason
and the reason of course is that
apprenticeships by definition are not
supposed to be the same as a kind of you
know full-time fully qualified job and
so you have this you have this
difference actually as it happens Vince
Cable my colleague in the in government
has increased the apprenticeship minimum
wage quite considerably by the largest
sort of percentage increase in recent in
recent years and thankfully if you look
at the average not your friends that you
luda to the average minimum wage pay to
apprentices is generally across the
country much much higher than that tends
to be well short of the six quid bits
often I think the average I can find out
for you I think it's over four over four
quid an hour but and so this is a really
difficult balance how do you make sure
that you get people in on
apprenticeships because it's such an
important conveyor belt to then getting
people into work how do you make sure
the employers feel they can you know
that it's worth it for them that it's
not too expensive but make sure that
it's not exploitative and I think
getting the balance by which is the way
we're trying to do it
increasing the statutory rate of the
apprenticeship minimum wage whilst at
the same time encouraging employers
which on the whole but on the whole they
do to pay more than that I think is the
right approach I think you simply whack
up the apprenticeship minimum wage so
the inverted commas normal minimum wage
you'll discourage lots of people from
taking apprenticeships and one of the
most exciting things in recent years is
the huge expansion of apprenticeships
we've seen under this government and
whilst yes we've saved some money
controversial in places like our
education we've poured money into print
into apprenticeships just recently we
had the first the first time ever the
two millionth new apprentice apprentice
take up an apprenticeship in this
country because of the massive expansion
in apprenticeships and they're just a
great way of as you know of combining
learning with working and I think it's
great that they're becoming so popular
trying to squeeze one more question in
from Facebook which now I'd like to know
Samantha wanted I'd like to know what
Nick like would do differently if he was
deputy prime minister again I said I
feel Frank Sinatra song coming on
exactly look I mean of course there are
there are individual decisions or
individual policies or individual
moments the rest of it where you kind of
think that I've done that better I've
expressed that better or explain that
better but in terms of the kind of where
was the country back in May 2010 and
where it is now I mean just incredibly
I'm incredibly proud and I'm not going
to hide from you of course my party's
suffered in the polls all the rest of it
that we stepped up to the plate because
I feel if the Liberal Democrats had not
done it you know we were kind of more or
less where Greece was back in may 2010
our deficit was almost exactly the same
as as Greece and and I just think now
that we've got more you know youth
unemployment now much lower than it was
when we came into office more
apprenticeships for youngsters than ever
before we've taken over 3 million people
on low pay out of paying any income tax
altogether got youngsters from poor
backgrounds receiving a healthy hot meal
at lunchtime for the first time ever
because of what we've done those are
things I'm proud of so I think it's
probably pride more than regret
thank you very honest as you know
Gregory and perhaps that's it for this
session Deputy Prime Minister Nick Clegg
thank you very much